today's Titanic tussle angel bees versus
robber beads these Central American
robber bees never trouble themselves to
visit actual flowers they make vera
living at larceny stealing what others
have already gathered the robber bees
are on the offense this morning they're
going to send a reconnaissance squad out
to test the angel bees defenses as you
can see the robber bees have a definite
size advantage but this angel squad
knows how to play defense
it's a one game series if they lose here
it's all over for the high that means
the angel bees have got to go forth they
have to play like there's no tomorrow
they have to give a hundred and ten
percent have I missed any sports cliches
oh yeah they have to put on their game
face and take it to a new level okay now
here's the key moment the angel bees
flood the zone hit the entire hive
against what looks to be a
the over man's troupe of robber beats oh
nice gang tackling the angel bees defend
themselves with a big swarm play just
like any great team they've got a game
plan and they're executing that plan to
perfection isolate the other guys
cripple them and take them down the
angel bees win it all
time to give the entire hive high-five
that's one honey of a victory okay I'll
stop